so I hear you're you're responsible for
his crippling video game addiction oh I
wouldn't call say the whole video game
addiction jeez yep that's me you all
right so I introduced
him oh [__] I introduced him to the
Bethesda like Moro wind and Fallout
that's the those are the two those are
the two and you went you went you went
dark deep into it like I was into it I
was like I had like a month where I was
like dude Bobby you're going to get so
immersed yeah and then like
four months later you're like I'm
collecting crysanthemum Batts like
you're you're like months later four
months later you're like I can I can if
you collect 100% pedals you can turn
them into an orb of and I was like who
cares who cares it's not a it's not a
the it's they they have uh online role
playing games now you can not for me no
I like here's what you introduced me to
the
Grind right like with Skyrim this cave
has all the blister mushrooms that you
can collect and they and it like what
regenerates every week right so I'll
fast forward a week in the game time
just so that I can get more blister wart
right so I can make potions to make
smithing better right which which was
kind of what I you know made me drop off
of the game at a certain point it felt
so like you could just grind forever yes
I love it and he's been grinding forever
it was like 10 years ago
yeah ago seriously it was it probably
was straight up 2007 I understand that I
understand 2007 but when let me say this
okay I would have never [__] known
about it if you didn't go hey you should
check out morrowwind I go what the [__]
is it so I went to [__] whatever the
place is you know to get it I bought it
and I've been in it since MH yeah and
you start over new characters yeah every
time because especially with the with
this the Bethesda game
and also um Skyrim or Elder Scrolls
there's eight
races right you can be a aoran mhm you
can be the um kajit the cat people no I
know I I've you know I've played the
games yeah know I know I
know you be
uh [__] yeah see what I'm saying right
now you be the the dark elves you could
be the light elves exactly right there
High Elves yeah they don't call them
yeah light elves they call
Adian
adriian yeah the um the lizards do you
ever find yourself like okay it's 3:30
in the morning 4 in the morning you're
just you're up in some like snowy hill
you're you
know beautiful music's playing and you
look out at the scenery and you realize
it's it's a dead world no it's an empty
dead World it comes to Al for me and it
doesn't lose you don't get that because
I think he's a conqueror at heart he's a
like you like to colonialized empty
Barren areas of land people don't know
this and if you do you don't but let me
tell you
do learn you learned learn and unlearn
okay is that when I my first show was
some people a lot of people know was Mad
TV and I
tested to get on the show with Taran it
was just you and I right just us yeah oh
and they were like which one would we
want go or regular white you know what I
mean or whatever right yeah yeah I'm
sure that's not what they say said in
the room how old were you 19 damn wow
and how old were you 30 who why does
that get the bigger
reaction which is you know a white 19
really yeah yeah in Asian years I'm same
age same age no we we hung out cuz we
met they brought us in for rehearsals
too and we met there we we went to
Hollywood center studios and did that
whole like studio session thing so it
was either you or him then no no oh oh
it was not like a we tested we we
auditioned uh rehearsed and then tested
together we played video games
afterwards that's right at the lot it
Fox at the time they had like two or
three upright video you know we want to
be retro games yeah yeah and we just
played in the lobby after after testing
I know and then saw Nico Cole in the
parking lot I feel she was like you guys
both did great don't worry about it and
then I got called that day I did too
yeah so but I I didn't see you again
until virgin mega store do you remember
that no I ran into you but like a week
maybe two later at virgin mega store at
Crescent Heights and Sunset and I didn't
know if you got it and I was like
Hey really yeah oh you didn't even all
right and you're like and I was like hey
um so I got it like yeah yeah yeah yeah
me too oh wow and and I was like oh and
then the first thing you said is have
you used it to get laid yet and I said
no no well yeah I think I probably my
voice
cracked you and you're like yeah yeah
yeah yeah three OU oh really yeah is
that what I that's oh my God some people
do impression exactly
exactly oh my God that is I hate I hate
it perfect it's so perfect this guy wow
yeah wow oh my God you almost [__]
killed me just now but bro don't ever do
that again by my I'm kidding you're so
good but I'm I'm um at my age now
I really believe it's not I I'm breaking
down 46 yeah yeah I mean I'm almost 50
man that's not that's fine what that's
fine I understand about that but I don't
live well okay well yeah that's an issue
so with the donuts right and I mean
there's some healthy snacks what do we
oh we got a jug of brittle okay we have
toffee brittle I hate that sh by these
dried mangoes these CH full of sugar all
sugar all right uh laqua
cucumber laqua have you ever let me ask
you something about laqua I know
sponsors no no what laa all of a sudden
this is the thing for sure it is it is
the zero calorie it's the flavoring but
it's still not necessarily great for you
because of the carbonation right for
your teeth in particular what does that
do what does it do with your now here's
a new paranoia now what does [__]
carbonation do to your teeth it it it it
ER the enamel and yeah if you if you are
constantly doing it if you you know they
there's videos online you can see if you
leave a tooth in so well Bobby doesn't
have enamel you want to tell him oh dear
he has four enamels total four four
of actually have maintained and and the
rest are just raw nerves just exposed
nerves just like just like whale
tee okay bailing stop going okay have
you seen what whale teeth look like it's
bailing it's like little straw there's
just certain things I've learned over
time you can chew meat with
gums you can it takes a while and it
hurts but you digest it better too maybe
yeah but you know back in the day when
you would see like homeless people with
no te how do they eat you gums gums you
know yeah all this back in time homeless
people look at my I look fine right you
look great when you like my teeth right
you look the same as when we met and I
look no you look exactly the same you
look more of a man you were boyish back
then I was very young yeah but all the
teeth that you see are the ones that
exist all right the back there is no
back okay yeah there is no back okay
because I don't uh floss yeah yeah I
brush but once a day okay and um I
didn't go to dentist for like 15 years
right but you go now yes so do you have
super teeth in the back you're not you
haven't done that yet just gums just raw
gums I wonder if they could put just one
giant M back there you know instead of
putting multiple MERS like Bond villain
tooth this a long one they just call him
Chomper he got like two giant metal they
likey Stimpy from Stimpy like a gigantic
block of tooth back there
red yeah over the
past uh two and a half like three years
uh well first my Budd Tommy blota
started doing a bunch of stuff with me
Tommy's a writer producer you'd be
familiar with a lot of the stuff that
he's done um big fan yeah and then um he
wrote on like the early uh he wrote on
like the first years of like late night
with con O'Brien and then Ali G show he
created that show Metalocalypse you know
that show oh I have it on Blu-ray okay
and uh you know a bunch of other stuff
and you know he does all that funny
things and then uh my good buddy Chad
culin if you met Chad also writer
albums I have Yellowstone National
Park Sky fever Sky fever I have um you
got that Duncan Pride that's a great
album it was a double album Duncan Pride
yeah Duncan Pride was a good Alum
remember the remember the track remember
the donuts we are Pride we are donuts we
are donuts we are donuts dun Pride I
love all that take it dunk it Che it m
mineral don't forget M mineral M mineral
that's what we need
we're down in the mine and you got tassy
nut yeah Tass nut that's what's up Taz
nut in the truck yeah ocean
holes
H we got to make Hol was great anyway so
it sort of turned into a very different
podcast very weird and then what we did
was we sort of started this thing called
The Diamond thing we realized that we
wanted to uh like a like you know like
like the like prehistoric vegetation
spinning turning into coal pressing down
and creating a a diamond you know we
want to I know how [__] diamonds made
you [__] [__] suckers we wanted to
take our audience and squish it down
until there's one Diamond left we we
essentially over the past year we've
lost all our sponsors our audience has
completely dropped off to where we only
have we've done it on purpose the show
got more and more inside
the jokes are impossible to get unless
you've listened to everything lot of
references to wrestling there's a lot of
stuff lot of useless [__] and we've had
a wonderful time pairing off our
wonderful audience to where now all we
have left is Diamond listeners okay and
from how many how many listeners are
there how many listeners right now
remember the Canadian math okay 140
people it might be a little more than
that I'm not sure I'm not going to math
I'm from Canada which means I'm stupid
okay so yeah thousands and thousands
less than used to yeah and uh so now
basically what we did was we listen all
these submissions from people like blah
blah blah C City that's what that's what
it is oh it's a [__] closed it's that
Closed Circuit City by the Del Taco on
Sunset that's what it is you used to
have you used to be Best Buy and now
you're C we used to be a Best Buy back
when people were [__] buying DVDs and
CDs and now we're the Circuit City
that's boarded up and his tagged gang
tags and [__] oh by the way kind of busy
you know acting in France my day job
that's true that is true you have been
working you have been working a yeah but
then it's like you know there's a lot of
things where it's like oh I'm trying to
get my thing popped off I want to do
this I want to make that you're writing
this you're doing that right and then
you don't and then that doesn't and
nothing but then but then a show says
you want to do a TV show and you go all
right I do some TV show sure sure excuse
me and I have a message to Tiger belly
fans right now this show tiger belly
don't I'm not Bobby and kalila no this
show right here will never be P off not
diamond yeah we're gonna have no diamond
di no no no diamonds right we are every
week going to be religious about giving
you content I love it all right and
there's no betrayal here I love it
George is not going to stab me in the
back like some people that I know right
this guy what's your name
again what Jason then Jason is literally
behind you sitting in the closet reach
behind him and just pull
look Bobby listen K I think that's
wonderful I think that's what a podcast
is about we are in the age of content
we've had I don't mind saying a pretty
funny conversation thus far oh I know
it's not over I think your audience is
going to like it there's a lot of
irreverent people talking in a room of
their house in the podcasting landscape
but this conversation's been pretty
good and that's what podcast should be
and at 10-minute podcast we've
completely betrayed that first of all
it's only 10 minutes to begin with so
that's dumb and then uh and now we're
just giving it away but yes like a like
like a like a like a Mystique painted
Orca breaching itself yeah in the in the
waters of South Africa yeah can anybody
name the songs from that band that I
named earlier any of the ocean holes
ocean holes is onece holes is one donut
Dan what was it donut Dan yeah the uh T
Tallahasse nut tah was tah nut what was
the sky one was another one sky fever
Sky fever something mineral yeah Sky
fever yeah yeah a Minal Min
mineral 96 96 uh now when I got on Mad
TV you were there did I wa say I I did
two seasons with you
you're asking me how many seasons yeah
no well I did with you specifically oh I
came on halfway during a season I think
you did another year after that I I went
through um God I don't even remember
what season uh middle of two middle of
wow season 4 maybe fall 5 six
seven8 middle of nine I left oh middle
of nine that was it and I started in
seven okay the seventh so I did a couple
years with you so yeah that F two and a
those were great years yes they were and
I relapsed I was 12 years sober I
relapsed and we were in Vegas and what
did I do in Vegas do you really want me
to see it yeah go say it oh wow can we
set it up so well we go to Vegas with I
think Baron Holtz was there for sure
there was a bunch T Ric was there the
gang that was fun oh my gosh those what
did I do what did I
do what did you do yeah yeah which which
moment in the bagio in the bagio in in
the hotel room wherever okay let's uh
take let's take the folks to the hotel
room okay room packed with our crew it
must have been I don't know at least 10
people maybe more yeah um Bobby had
brought along a a a a pal if you will
um uh he he I believe flew her in yeah
um specifically remember and paid her to
do
so perhaps okay uh lovely gal beautiful
um what I remember is I myself was
sitting at one point now this it was a
crazy time but I'm sitting up on the bed
uh
and yeah wow it really comes back to the
to the brain the
visual Bobby comes out of the bathroom
fully naked like trying to pull off a
hat trick like he's rubbing his belly
with one hand and the other hand was
jerking his
wings hey my room my my rules so he's
he's doing you know that that's sort of
like where people do where they sounds
this sounds like he was doing this very
hard to do well that was the first time
I had ever done ecstasy oh and so I was
drinking and then ecstasy and it really
like it you mean when you when you're in
your 30s and you hear about this drug
and people especially when you're sober
in your 30s and people go and then when
you relapse and you finally do it it
just kind of hit me in a weird way do
you do you remember do you remember even
uh before this moment flying to Vegas I
think it was that trip yeah what what we
sat next to each other on the plane
before take off you you pull out a
baggie yeah thank God it was a baggie
yeah loaded with pills like I had never
it was it looked like you know
children's toys candy it was a bag of
adult candy and I panicked cuz you know
I'm a good Irish Catholic girl from
innesa Wild I've had some moment you're
[__] I've had some moments it's not
even moments just let's just get this a
real out there okay you're wild I've had
you're Wild done some things all right
so go ahead but I I panicked cuz I'm
just thinking the steward this is going
to come along I don't know I don't know
what happens and of course you eat some
no you never ate out of my pills no oh I
didn't no I definitely didn't I was a
drinker Dr you were yeah yeah yeah um
cuz I know some people that I didn't no
I didn't know what you had but I paniced
and and then they started sping all over
do you know what I mean like he's like
I'm like Bobby no no I there's I took
this Vegas trip you know to partly to
like get away from uh being a mother I
had a little child back at home and here
I am Bobby no Bob put your pills away
Bobby you know and that was intense I'll
tell you another story that a mo then
she's going to bring up these things
right somebody invited me
here we there was like a TCA party for
you know at the mandre was it the mandre
how dare you what what do you mean how
dare you you did it yeah I did you did
it I did how dare you how dare
me right right this is this is the way
this is no it's just like you know at a
TCA party right now you're you have
everyone's in Ballroom gowns and you
know the executives are there and people
are just have this woman she's in a
ballroom gown she's in the pool okay
love it no one's in the pool MH oh no
that's not true true what who was else
in there the mermaids were in the pool
the actor they were yeah you know how at
parties they'll hire yeah they'll hire
mermaids oh they were mermaids there
which is that's why I went in I went to
be a mermaid I don't do things without
good reason that's valid that's valid
but yeah uh it was the big fox party and
I just heels and all crazy that night
just boom boom boom right down into the
pool and started floating and I yeah
then I threw up in the um limo on the
way home did you really going up and
over Laurel oh yeah I did and uh then
the next day or the Monday whatever uh I
got called into the office so because
they had to do damage control yeah on me
oh really yeah they did you were wild
that night yeah but that still is seems
like a pretty benign when you're
drinking here's another thing I know
about not the best idea here's what
here's why you do so like part of you
thinks and at least in that c crazy
brain is like well I'm on the sketch
comedy show I'm supposed to be crazy we
can get away with this stuff yeah right
M no yeah I know do you have a positive
memory of Bobby or was it just the drug
lace debauchery oh I have I want to know
what he was like in his 30s cuz I
already know him in his 40s and he seems
a little bit more settled and I I have
this sick curiosity for how I wonder and
I imagine if I would have gotten along
with him at that age Bobby was
lovely we would sit outside the building
yeah we would sit outside the building
like just uh between whatever rehearsals
or whatever and uh have a cigarette yeah
sometimes you know and just sit down
there and we would just have life
conversations you know I would I
remember uh you feeling insecure and
worried about it and talking to you and
telling you it's going to be all right
you know I remember a time just before
stepping out onto stage at one of the
live shows and you were uh backstage
with me and you were freaking out like
right right behind the door we were
about to enter you know and and I was
just I remember that moment very vividly
you know that I I was just like Bobby
you lucky son of a [__] you get to go
out there and play in front of these
people with me
yeah like let's just go out and have fun
that's all you have to do right that's
not that's not hard that's that's just
abandon yourself to what's good for you
you know so we had a we had a lot of
conversations we had a lot of really
sweet
conversations you know it's like it
isn't all the crazy that you know I led
in with yeah it wasn't it really wasn't
that yeah you know um we've had good no
we know dinners and you know and all
that we we used to go after lives we
used to go to that one French place on
Los P that place called
La something like
that no there was one over there that we
used to go
every live but it was fun and then um
and then everyone would go like you know
all the writers and producers and also
some you friends family whatever it was
a fun night but um this one here's how I
how why I can say that though is because
you know when you're sitting there and
you're watching
like her play Lorraine or whatever and
then they do a pass where it's like all
improvised or do what you want to do and
just how crazy like so just in terms of
adding information that
quickly you know in in a live
environment with the cameras on and
you're sitting there Indian style going
wow I've never you know I mean I didn't
grow up with yeah Sketch you know but
you're learning so fast and you're
trying to absorb everything right and
then it's just like watching someone
like that you go holy [__] like that was
insane you know like Keegan would do
that too Keegan Keys would do Coach
Hines and then do a take where he just
the whole thing is completely and
utterly different mhm but also like
somebody had written it or like it took
a week and wrote it yeah but it wasn't
it was just all improvised and you just
kind of go oh [__] I I should go
home what am I doing you know I mean
what the [__] am I doing here yeah but
um yeah uh we were on there from 2002 to
2007 together my God and I'm going to
say something I have some apologies that
I have to do no yeah I'm going to you
don't have to but I want to because I'll
tell you why um I've been thinking about
some of my behaviors back in the day and
I just want to just uh apologize number
one I want to apologize for one day you
and Nicole Parker were riding in dick
loui's office right wow and he had some
Toms on his desk mhm and I jammed in my
butthole yes my butthole started
foaming it was crazy it was crazy I know
my butthole started forming I shot out a
couple of um pellets pellets right a
little poo came out and then dick was
mad but you laughed but in my mind I'm
like I don't think that's the right
Behavior once people are right am I not
right I didn't am I right can we get a
consensus in the room yeah that's not
good behavior it was funny yeah I I was
fine with it you're fine with it I was
fine with it I Remember You Came my
dressing room one time and you literally
were like you're like I'm gonna take a
[__] out your floor and I was like don't
don't and you just [__] took a [__]
right in front of me yeah yeah and it
was like very anticlimactic cuz I went
clean it up and you were like you just
have to get your knees and clean but
that's not normal behavior well no it
wasn't it wasn't hey it was the
2000 George W [__] was our president I
uh but it was like we were all everyone
was crazy then like any any every day we
were there there's like 10 things
happened that would have gotten people
fired my God yeah and then I'll the last
thing I want that's just the
sketches the last thing I want to um
apologize about I you me and Josh were
doing Ben we had a promote remember back
then we had a promote and went to Ben
glebs talk show or something oh this I
do remember you don't apologize to me
you don't apologize to Mrs
Glee Oh yeah what happened what happen
what happened I I I mean again these
These Memories like come in like I'm
almost like a like a Vietnam
vet that like like has just flashbacks
of like the name you know uh but I do
remember like we were promoting
something in Ben Glee who was a comedian
or he was a talk show he was like a dude
yeah he was a dude he talk show dude
yeah yeah and he had us on and he's like
we're going to do a fun bit I have this
woman who's a like a fortune teller
fortune teller yeah yeah yeah and and
Josh and I knew it was a bit and we were
just playing along with a bit and Bobby
was
like Bobby was like this is [__]
[__] you're a liar I don't think
everything you say it's [__] I'm not
I'm not down with this like he was so
mean to so mean to her to this woman and
then we found out it was it was Ben
Glee's
mom yeah I was being such a dick but
also in the green room I was doing weird
things like I was stuffing stuff in my
bottle just weird stuff why do you think
um why do you think you wanted to like
self hey John what what's up you're my
boy huh for life I have a question like
why do you think you always wanted to do
anal on yourself he's
gay that who said that why' you say that
because you I was just yeah I know but
I'm not you know mean you threw that out
there you they clip that you know what I
mean I'm gay does it feel good I don't
mind I I'm supportive of the lglg you
know what I mean but course yeah but
it's weird because you don't let any
fingers up there but why did you keep
shoving [__] up your ass when you were I
think at the time I didn't have the
talent yourself I know I know but in my
mind I'm like oh these guys can do
Impressions and they're like and they
can do like excuse me sir no one does a
better Connie Chung in this e 50 United
States than you I don't know and you
know I mean they they can do characters
and they this is their thing right so in
my mind I'm like oh I'll just be weird
but that 2000s don't you feel like
everyone back then was like in the 2000s
like look at my dick hole comedy was
like you know what I mean it was just so
gross which I loved I was a huge fan of
it I still am I showed my dick hole to a
couple people this morning um but uh I
think at that time it was just everyone
was like crazy we just like people were
just nuts yeah yeah and I I I I find
myself apologizing people like you know
Flanigan I farted in her mouth that one
again you never have to apologize to me
there was never a day where I was
driving home and I was like [__] Bobby
yeah but like fling and I get that
that's a good yeah that was yeah he
farted and I saw her hair
move like literally like I saw the wind
from his yeah yeah yeah yeah ass I've
seen your if you right now the Lights
Went Out in the studio and you just put
a Sharpie in my hand I could draw your
[__] like every every lip every
muscle thank you thank you thank you I
love it sano's very good on Dave I got
to say he's really good Dave is a very
good great show that this last season
was [__] phenomenal so that last
episode with Brad Pit with with Brad Pit
but with the the girl who was like
holding them kind of H who the [__] was
she I don't know I've never SE she was
incredible I've never seen
it I refuse I ref ref watch
jealousy can you not watch I know watch
I know watch that's funny is there are
there things that you just can't watch
because of just just emotion no it's not
cuz there's I have a couple things like
that no well number one I don't know
about you but I'm not a comedy guy you
can't watch Comedy yeah I'll watch no
I'll watch what do you watch it I watch
the boys okay because it's infused with
it's a great show and there's comedy in
it I like I love secession fantastic F
fantastic show um and the humor is dark
enough where I it just kind of rings
trueth for me but in general I just
don't watch comedies I don't know you
remember we did a sketch with my
dad you it was me
my dad there he is right there Beau
there he is there he is he turn he turns
to uh uh Bobby at one point he goes
Bobby they're be very
tired and Bobby goes and he like nodded
like he knew what to do and walks over
to a PA and gives him like a 50 and goes
I need you to go to the corner store and
get my father a beer and a Clamato yeah
whoa and they went and got G when he
relapsed he was a Clamato guy Clamato
Clamato guy yeah well if you're going to
relapse it's good to drink the most
disgusting [__] in
it's funny cuz after mat TV I you know
Comedy Central gave me a pilot right so
my dad was on the pilot yeah and wrote
him this monologue which was a mistake
because my dad shows up and he's scared
you can tell yeah and they said he put
him on his Mark and I go uh we go
action and he looks at inside the into
the camera and he just ran off
a I remember when we did the sketch with
your mom and she she hit me she SLA me
in the face oh yeah yeah and she was
also like I like Han Solo try to like
hit on
me it was uh it was great good time so
let's get your little beef out and I'm
going to tell you what I had a problem
with okay well before we get to that let
me just say to you let me say to you say
this to you and I mean this sincerely
from the bottom of my heart man Bobby I
need you to look at me no this is
important you have to one eye okay one
eye when you had both eyes open cuz you
Asian so it was oneeyed
in racist but let's move on but funny um
very funny uh I sincerely apologize to
you man uh forever if for making you
feel some kind of way uh uh and you know
for any discomfort I may have caused you
uh during our ten year together uh over
on mad and uh thank you for allowing me
to finally come here so we could hash
this out and we could you know uh make
everything right man you know some
Jackie Chan Chris Tucker [__]
I love this maybe we could do Rush Hour
four if Chris falls out of
place yeah okay was really nice your
turn you know I can I say this when you
walked in here I did not recognize you
it wasn't just your way there's
something just about your energy okay
that's completely I don't know what you
did landmar Forum you know LIF spring or
something you read a book or something
but I've been rehearsing this for two
weeks
man pretty good dude you memorized it
yeah so and you know and I I accept that
right and you know honestly I don't I
don't have a problem it's just that I
like talking [__] it's how I make a
living right so it's just I just say
things and it backfires because I run
into people and stuff so but I really
don't never really had an issue so let
if you remember we had you could count
all the black writers on on Mad TV on
three fingers we had three we had three
black writers yeah so yes other writers
would write for us meaning me and
Deborah the black folks but really the
people that were assigned to us and to
me specifically was Devon Shephard and
when he was there his man uh Xavier
xavia cook I love those two guys but
Devon was my main guy if he was like my
Georgio armman if I needed a suit he
knew my measurements comedically we
would like that yeah so I'm saying that
to say we we know that this business is
political we know that it's racist and a
lot of times Devon and I would have to
fight for sketch time everybody's
fighting for sketch time but really as a
black person you're really fighting cuz
you know we could sit there and read a
whole table read worth of sketches and
you might be lucky some weeks if you're
in one there would be times when you'd
be in none and so you you fighting for
sketch time and and the and the concern
was because you were maybe you know
dyslexic yeah your substance abuse
problems I'm not dyslexic I don't know
why you're putting that out there you
kidding me you can give me a book right
now I can read the whole thing in front
of you okay I'm going with her right now
she's three and 0 give me a parir give
me a book right now she told you you
didn't have a ice and you thought you
had ice yeah yeah okay go just she she
hooked us up talk about later go ahead I
I didn't say you were illiterate I said
you were dyslexic you would flip things
around and when under the pressure you
mix things up all right let me but let
me say this because of the dyslexia
because of the substance abuse which get
I didn't have don't have dyslexia I
don't have dyslexia let's just say you
do it helped your case you're so unaware
most men are but I this one is special
anyway so and and the fact read that
again naps are awesome oh no I'm about
to prove your point Bobby would let me
talk to her for a minute because Bobby
wasn't great at reading at the table
read he would often tank sketches not on
purpose but because he was so
awful without looking at each other we
would know like telepathy well that's a
sketch I'm not going to be in it's not
going to get picked [__] you once
pronounced opinion
Buick it was in the script the word
opinion this [__] said
Buick